Now we're going to
talk about collections.
There's almost no need for
a formal definition here,
since a collection is, as the name
implies, just a group of things.
You could have a collection of books,
a collection of Udacity employees, or
even a collection of desk animal
things that I talk to when I'm
stuck on programming projects and
the coaches aren't around.
Let's make a few observations here.
Collections don't have
a particular order.
You could shuffle some elements around
and it wouldn't make a huge difference.
Similarly, we couldn't say, give me
the third element in this collection,
since there's no inherent order.
Collections also don't need to
have the same type of object.
Everything in the room could be in the,
around the dusty office collection,
even though there are books and
people and animal things.
A collection on its own really
isn't something you can use in
a programming language.
However, there are many data structures
that are extensions of collections.
So, they just add more rules to the ones
that already apply for collections.
Let's take a look at some of those now